good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight looking back the
immigration and nationality act of 1965
turned out to be one of the most
significant pieces of legislation ever
passed by the u.s congress now the
people who wrote it knew that it would
be so naturally spent a lot of time
trying to convince everyone else that in
fact it was no big deal
this is not a revolutionary bill assured
lyndon johnson when he signed it the
first tip that it was in fact a
revolutionary bill and then there was
this on the senate floor ted kennedy of
massachusetts the man who drove the bill
went out of his way to explain that the
democratic party was absolutely not
trying to replace the american
population with more compliant
foreign-born voters no way that's an
insane conspiracy theory he explained
quote
this bill will not flood our cities with
immigrants kennedy said it will not
upset the ethnic mix of our society it
will not relax the standards of
admission it will not cause american
workers to lose their jobs
it's all bitterly amusing when you look
back at it because of course that is
precisely what this bill did this bill
changed america completely and forever
and the numbers show it in the years
since that legislation passed the united
states total population exploded by
140 million people you're seeing that
chart on your screen right now what
direction is the point well steadily
upward that's the population
now where did all those people come from
there's nothing wrong with more people
the question is
who are they and where do they come from
well what you're seeing is not the kind
of organic growth that you would see in
a healthy society that's become more
prosperous and welcoming of families
it's not like people were so confident
in the future they decide to have more
kids
you know it's just the opposite exactly
the opposite of that in fact
since ted kennedy's bill became law
birth rates among native born americans
which are the clearest possible measure
of optimism in the future
those have dropped off a cliff and
you're seeing that chart on the screen
now it's the inverse of the first chart
this chart points downward
in 2020 the most recent year for which
we have data the overall fertility rate
in the united states hit the lowest
point ever recorded and that was before
covid
this country is now well under the
so-called replacement level that means
if we continue on this trajectory and no
one's trying to take us off this
trajectory eventually there will be no
more native born americans
so you put these two graphs together and
what do they show you well they show you
a number of things but here's the main
one
sometime around 1965 our leaders stopped
trying to make the united states a
hospitable place for american citizens
their constituents to have their own
families
that used to be considered the central
task of leadership
perpetuating
the population if people are happy and
confident they'll have kids they're
vested in the society and if they're not
they won't that was their job
so they stopped doing it and instead
they just imported new people
that's literally what happened now
you're not allowed to point this out of
course the media become absolutely
hysterical when you do because it's so
obviously true what's interesting is
that if something like this happened in
any other country say in china or japan
or nigeria the populations of those
countries would likely revolt
because you can't do that
the leaders of a country can't change
the population of the country especially
the democracy without the consent
of the existing population
so if those populations and say nigeria
for example revolted the new york times
should be deeply sympathetic to their
outrage again you can't just replace the
electorate because you didn't like the
last election outcomes that would be the
definition of undermining democracy
changing the voters
but when it happens in this country
there is mandatory media enforced
silence in fact if you notice it's
happening
it's your fault you're immoral you're a
racist
but it has nothing to do with race it's
about change and it's absolutely real
the majority of population growth since
1965 has come from immigration not from
americans having more kids
in 1965 the number of permanent illegal
migrants in this country from latin
america was essentially zero they were
migrant farm workers but there were no
huge populations people living here
illegally by 2008 that number had grown
to perhaps 20 million people
they lied about it but the best
estimates suggest
it was tens of millions
and then came joe biden
joe biden accelerated that sad trend
beyond what anyone thought was possible
the foreign-born population is now
growing by a hundred and thirty-two
thousand people every month
that's more than triple the average high
under previous administrations it's
double barack obama's highest totals
according to ei scholar mark perry we
can expect over nine
million new illegal aliens by the end of
joe biden's first term
nothing like this has ever happened in
this or maybe any other country ever
and it's happening for one reason it's
not natural it's the product of a policy
choice joe biden promised amnesty to
anyone who makes it across our border
so in 2019 for example the trump
administration criminally prosecuted 110
000 illegal migrants for violating
immigration law not that they were bad
people some of them are great people but
you're not allowed to go into someone
else's country without permission that's
what a law is and if you ignore the law
you are no longer a real country you're
something less than that you're a failed
state
so you have to enforce the law including
immigration law
but joe biden stopped doing it
last year joe biden prosecuted fewer
than 3 000 total that's according to dhs
data obtained by the washington free
beacon it's a drop of nearly 98 percent
so naturally people are coming
because
why wouldn't you want to move to the
united states
knowing that when you get here you will
be treated like someone who deserves to
be here and given every possible public
benefit you'd be crazy not to come and
so they are in massive numbers and then
traveling often at public expense paid
for by you without your knowledge
throughout the united states watch one
border agent explain what exactly is
happening
dps officers have been assisting border
patrol under operation lone star for 16
months in that time they've apprehended
279
000 undocumented migrants arrested 17
000 criminals and seized nearly
320 million lethal doses of fentanyl
every state has become a border state
because all these individuals that are
coming across
aside from the families the single
adults the godaways the drugs that are
coming in are going to other states
they're not staying in texas that's
mexico there so they'll come across
they'll bring them across on a raft
because they usually have 30 40
you know immigrants on these rafts
they're bringing them across they know
where to drop them off and they know
where to walk
so here's another thing that's changed
since 1965 along with our population
politicians no longer feel they need to
pretend partly because the population is
so different you've got a lot more
people with permanent jobs in american
politics so unlike lyndon johnson joe
biden didn't pretend
that his goal was not to change the
population he said it out loud during
the campaign biden referred to illegal
immigration as a gift watch
guess what
they're the reason why
the legal as well as undocumented the
reason why our society is functioning
the reason why our economy is growing we
don't talk about that we stand up and
act like it's a burden it is not a
burden
it's a gift
it's a gift says a man who has worked in
a public job his entire life who's never
had a real job ever is lecturing you
about the economy and how it works as if
he knows by the way in that tape joe
biden
was so senile that his wife and his
handlers gave him drugs before that
interview that interview that you just
saw so that's the guy telling you about
the economic benefits
of illegal immigration
now mostly you're not supposed to notice
that that conversation even took place
just like you're not supposed to notice
when the new york times prints an op-ed
called we can replace them
because that's a dangerous conspiracy
theory what are you alex jones
no
we just watch carefully not even that
carefully they say it constantly
the great replacement
yeah it's not a conspiracy theory
it's their electoral strategy and we
know that because they say it
all the time here's some examples
blue wave is african-american
it's white it's latino it's asia pacific
islander it is made up of those who've
been told that they are not worthy of
being here
it is comprised of those who are
documented and undocumented in a couple
of presidential cycles you'll be on
election night you'll be announcing that
we're calling the 38 electoral votes of
texas for the democratic nominee for
president it's changing it's going to
become a purple state and then a blue
state because of the demographics the
demographics of america are not on the
side of the republican party
the new voters in this country are
moving away from them
instead they're moving to be
independents already even vote on the
other side an unrelenting stream of
immigration
non-stop
nonstop
folks like me who were
caucasian of european descent
for the first time in 2017 we'll be in
an absolute minority in the united
states of america
absolute minority
fewer than 50 percent of the people in
america from then and on
will be
white european stock
that's not a bad thing that's that's a
source of our strength
so how is that a source of our strength
he never explained
so clearly it's the source of the
democratic party's strength they believe
though actually that plan might not work
out for them since a lot of the people
arriving may not be sympathetic to joe
biden who possibly could be
but electoral politics are really
secondary to the real concern which is
the stability of the country
so the problem with what the democratic
party is doing right now is not simply
that it helps the democratic party
though we think that's bad
the problem is that they're doing it way
too fast
this is too much change at once for any
society ever at any point in history no
society can metabolize this many new
people
and stay stable especially not now in
this specific moment because two
unprecedented waves of human migration
you have to add let's see
a collapsing economy inflation food
shortages skyrocketing housing prices
falling wages the trauma of two and a
half years of covet the manufactured
racial strife you saw joe biden himself
encouraging
you put all that together and you have
the most volatile possible mix of social
factors
so into that you throw millions of brand
new people who have no connection to
america whatsoever people who broke our
laws to get here who don't speak our
language who have no idea what the us
constitution says and don't care
and what do you have when you put all
that together you have a recipe for
social collapse
this is why no sane government would
ever do this the chinese government
would never consider doing this
even corrupt dumb governments that can't
even keep a national airline flying
would never do something like this to
their own countries because they don't
want their own countries to collapse
and it's not an attack on the people
coming here by the way some of whom are
legitimately great people and want to be
here for the right reasons
the problem is the volume
no country can withstand what we're
going through right now
and in our specific case it turns out
that a lot of the people coming are not
ready to participate in a democracy
a huge percentage of the migrants across
the border today are functionally
illiterate
according to the center for immigration
studies 41 of the immigrants score at or
below the lowest level of english
literacy a level variously described as
below basic or functionally illiterate
now add to this the problems that
american-born people are having with
english after two years of covid and
suspended education
and a life spent staring into a screen
what does that look like
a lot of people who are moving here are
not becoming assimilated we know that
because many haven't learned english
after living here for years the same
study found that 67
of hispanic immigrants do not develop
english proficiency even after 15 years
of living united states that means
around 5 million migrants became
citizens without even being able to
speak our language
once again
not an attack on them an attack on the
people running the country this could
capsize the united states this is a huge
sprawling country with a massive
population so the question from day one
has always been
what holds everyone together what is the
one thing we all have in common it's not
an ethnic group it's not a shared
history now it's not a language so what
is it
well in the absence of glue
things break apart that's a physic
principle
so no one who cared about the future of
this country would do this to the
country it is truly insanity and yet the
biden administration
is trying to make it worse working hard
to make it worse fox news is reporting
tonight that the administration awarded
172 million grant to a george
soros-linked organization which exists
to quote help young border crossers
avoid deportation
now why is some foreign-born billionaire
allowed to change our country
fundamentally that's the big question
here are the specifics this
organization's called the vera institute
for justice and it stands to gain a
billion dollars in federal money by the
end of the contract just to subvert our
laws
now the catch is that no one verifies
whether the people crossing the border
are actually minors
right you can't know who they are by
definition they're here illegally
and after 9 11 didn't we care about the
authenticity of documents didn't we have
a real id act
but we don't know how old they are and
that's how 24 year old medina uloa was
able to enter this country and murder a
father of four in the backyard of his
house in florida in october he posed as
a child so that joe biden would fly him
at your expense to jacksonville in the
middle of the night
so courtesy of the biden administration
unaccompanied minors like medina uloa
are also arriving in new york in texas
louisiana tennessee and arizona and many
other places
according for example to 12 news in
phoenix representatives from phoenix sky
harbor international airport reported
that hundreds of migrants showed up
recently with no booked tickets
roughly three to four hundred refugees
have arrived every single day by bus in
recent months so why are all of these
illegal aliens arriving in phoenix well
many of them were dropped off by a
non-profit called
rcbh
which brags has helped nearly 20 000
illegal aliens released by immigration
authorities without charges
moving all over the country and that's
where it's happening all over the
country
in brownsville texas fox news observed
buses contracted by the buy
administration dropping off dozens of
male migrants at a parking garage
our reporters witness those migrants go
into an unmarked office then get picked
up by taxi cabs and driven to the
airport none of them were children
commercial airline pilots right now are
being told to fly these people all over
the country we spoke to a pilot who's
doing it every day and we're quoting we
are breaking the law transporting
illegals many of whom are unaccompanied
minors
why is this continuing because neither
party is interested in stopping it on
this question as on foreign policy
there's only one party the uniparty and
it's aligned against your most basic
interests no matter what color you are
by the way
instead both parties are finding new
ways to give american jobs to
foreign-born applicants 62 republicans
just joined to their eternal shame with
almost every single democrat in the
house to pass the national defense bill
now tucked away in that 840 billion
dollar piece of legislation is a plan to
give away even more american jobs to
foreign workers as if we need this now
so now the children of h-1b visa workers
will receive citizenship
because their parents took jobs in this
country huh how does that work exactly
shut up racist
again it's not about race it's about
economics and social cohesion
both of which they're destroying now
according to our congress fewer jobs for
americans somehow makes this country
safer that's been their plan since 1965
and since 1965 both parties have
supported it
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight